hi I'm Nickie for reason TV and we're at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and we're
talking to Jee Epstein who works at
Barons the economic news weekly Jean
thanks for talking to us pleasure you
are among many things you are a strong
follower of Murray rothar you know at an
event like this you run into a lot of
people rothbardian anti- rothbardian Etc
how do you take the measure of Murray
rothbard the Renegade Austrian School
Economist influence on the Contemporary
libertarian movement I think he was
basically the most influential he was
really uh Plato to ludik vanus Socrates
ludik vanus came from Austria he was a
Jewish Refugee from Nazism and uh he
came to New York in
1949 and he set up a seminar at NYU and
rothbart who was then a Columbia
graduate student attended his seminar
and while ree is published splendidly in
English it was really left to rothbard
who was a gifted writer to take mises's
ideas and extend them to some degree
make them clearer and uh apply them now
so let's take that into the libertar
movement how did how did rothbard kind
of popularize maian understanding of you
know of of the economy or Of Human
Action to to a broader audience well I
think he uh popularized it mainly uh
through His Brilliant writing uh he was
a guy from Brooklyn uh with a very sort
of downhome style very straightforward
and simple misus was a German uh a
little bit more complicated in the way
he wrote so rothbard more than any
Economist taught me uh to understand the
ways in which government is an actor in
the economy government is not the
philosopher king uh it's not the over
it's not the and it's not the referee
not the referee yeah it is it it's a an
actor that has its own interests and its
own ambition yeah to some degree uh
James you Canon public Choice Theory
contributed to that and rothbart mainly
had respect for that that clearly
government politicians bureaucrats
officials they all act on their own
incentives and uh and they're all in
lots of ways fumbling as well now
rothbart in the uh in the 60s in the
late 60s he pioneered an you know
attempts to kind of create a fusion
between radicals on the far left as well
as libertarian radicals uh you know was
that successful uh or why why why was it
not successful I don't think so no I
know I think Ro rothbart clearly had a
combative personality uh he was not made
not cut out for politics he uh I think
he unnecessarily to some degree at least
uh impune other free market economists
uh Ronald Co for example he got CO as in
all a Nobel prize winning no priz
winning I think had some good ideas and
rothbart caricatured him so he's a man
of many flaws even even as an
intellectual he wasn't totally fair to
some of the people that criticize but
certainly as somebody who operated tried
to operate in the political Arena he was
clearly perverse in in the late ' 80s I
mean he he worked a lot with Ron Paul
and with Lou Rockwell and whatnot but at
a certain point he also kind of broached
a uh romance or a bromance maybe of
David Duke and of kind of a southern
populism where did that come from and
does that fit in his larger intellectual
project of you know of kind of talking
about economics clearly I like to think
not I do recommend for example to people
a book that he wrote a popular book
called for a new Liberty I believe that
virtually every chapter in that is fresh
and makes sense and and adheres uh to
the proper line and and and makes good
distinctions fair-minded distinctions
but in uh when it came to politics it
brought the worst out when it came to
this de the devious way in which he for
example he Allied himself with with Pat
Buchanan all of that just made no sense
uh where he really did not belong but of
course his output as an as a as an
intellectual was just astonishing uh 25
books thousands of Articles uh a massive
amount of uh material worth do so what
what's the enduring if it's if it's
possible to sum up his legacy uh you
know and the message that he should be
sending to the Contemporary libertarian
movement what's the best message we can
take out of Roth's work so many really
uh in a way to choose one would be uh to
uh uh uh to diminish him uh certainly
his message about that the origins of
money money begins from a commodity no
government could create money uh
government gets involved with money
because it wants to fight its Wars
because now it wants to finance the
wealth Warfare State uh the uh the last
thing government should be involved in
is money rather they should be producing
shoes the shoes will pinch but we'll
wear sandals money is the last thing
they should be involved in uh his
contribution to uh an understanding of
how government control of a money supply
produces business Cycles U his
understanding of of how wages rise his
Insight by the way uh that that Capital
uh gets no Capital gets no returns the
only returns are land and labor
capitalists get returns because they're
entrepreneurs because they take risks
his explanation of Interest
all of that very very clear um so that
if you read man economy and state for
example his fundamental book about
Austrian economics uh you'll learn most
of what is valuable in economics 95% of
what you have to read is that book yeah
all right well we will leave it there
Jee Epstein of Barons thanks for talking
about the Legacy and life of uh Murray
rothbart at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas
for raison TV I'm Nick
kesie